[Music]
so if you're into doctor who obviously
there's the show modern era and classic
playing it at you on there but if you
want more stuff well there's a number of
places to go
there's novels
novelizations of episodes comic books
but
most fans turn
to big finish
the audio dramas which feature
all manner of characters and returning
cast members from all errors of the show
and i
had the joy of getting to speak with
jason hey gallery who is the managing
director
over at big finish
now there's a bit of a lengthy
conversation we go over a lot of stuff
including the history of the company the
history of its relationship with doctor
who in particular and a number of other
tangents along the way there is going to
be an instance towards the back end
latter half of the video where it is
going to suddenly drop in with a later
conversation that he and i had basically
because we realized there was an element
that we had missed in uh in a specific
topic that's gonna come up so just be
aware that that's coming otherwise
enjoy
so jason thank you so much for uh for
coming on and actually i was going to
say agreeing to suggesting that you come
to talk
i was i was just saying just now that um
you know i used to watch you
um on youtube and i think your your
videos are excellent about the series
but also about big finish which is
obviously lovely um and it was a bit of
a surprise to see you at gallifrey i
don't know why it was a surprise but i
saw you went oh
it's that person from
council of geek you know
it is funny like you there's the people
are like on the in the program you're
like oh i know that like i'll see these
people but then there's the people you
just wonder you just run into wandering
around like oh
i'd like i had that as well with both
creative people and like people i follow
and tick tock and all this other stuff
but it still throws you off even though
you know you're all there for the same
reason
it's weird isn't it it's just by virtue
of the fact you're in a small frame
when you meet them like face to face it
just feels totally different doesn't it
it really does so um for those uh
viewers who may not know if you don't
mind sort of giving your current
position within big finish and like just
a quick overview of your history within
the company
so my name is jason hey gallery i am the
chairman and co-executive producer of
big finish
and i started the company in around
about 94
and in 1998 we moved into audio drama
uh which we did originally with bernie
summerfield
and then we got the license to do doctor
who in early 1999
and in fact i went to the gallifrey
convention in 1999
and they were like oh there's no new
doctor who there's nothing here where
are we going will they ever come back in
any way and we were sitting there going
because we knew but we couldn't tell
anyone that we got the license
and uh so that was there was a lot of
knowing looks between us all um
and
yeah and then
we brought back doctor who was sirens of
time
um starring peter davison colin baker
and sylvester mccoy who were the
three doctors that we knew at the time
and um what what what era is your doctor
who era when you started watching doctor
so i like i came in i got hooked in um
by tenant
um but then uh once i saw that i went
back to the start of series one with
ecclestone and caught up i've been
watching the show as it airs since
series four that's where i came into
things and i've obviously gone back and
i've taken in
as much classic as i have the time for
because there's a lot of it and you know
into things like big finish but that's
that's that's where i came in
right so i go back to pertwee was my
first doctor
and um it was one of my biggest regrets
is the fact that unfortunately didn't
start fast enough
to work with pertwee
because that would have been amazing and
i i talked to elizabeth sladen about
this
um
when we were doing the sarah jane smith
adventures that we did
uh elizabeth said oh
john would have been banging your door
down to do these because he loved
playing the path so much i was a
teenager when when peace davidson was
the doctor
and i
really appreciated his doctor because he
was not in it felt like he wasn't that
much older than me in some respects
so
he really appealed to me as a doctor i
understand how
um matt smith especially had
a lot of support amongst the fans
because
a lot of the fans were of a similar age
in some respects
but i i actually had that same thing
part of the reason why i took to him so
much was
he and i are basically the same age so
that was the point i'm like oh
it's like i could be the doctor well
this you actually look a lot younger may
just say
thank you
but uh but yes it it it is that aspect
isn't it so when we got back with
simon's a time
peter was very exciting for me
colin i
got into fandom a lot by the time colin
was the doctor
and then sylvester was was again fandom
so it was very exciting to get the three
of them back to do that first story
there's a photograph which is on the net
of me and uh
and guy russell and nick and
uh oh god it's come out of my head
anyway hey another person that's
terrible it will come back to me in a
moment and we're all drinking champagne
and celebrating the fact we got the
doctors back into the studio
and uh we took and i think they must
have been a bit like what the hell's
going on when we got them in there and
we were recording because we were so
excited
it was like giving a load of kids
smarties before we
we sat down to do the recording um
and then it progressed from there we
originally were going to do
six productions a year for three years
and we felt that if we did 18
productions
then that would be
um that would be an achievement and
something that was a bit of a legacy for
us and we would have
done our bit for doctor who you said i
mean the irony now of course is that
that's basically what we release every
month
so
it's a bit like that and within uh i
think it was within three months of us
launching
i had to contact gary and say you know
how you do this as a part-time job it's
not a part-time job and secondly you
know how we're gonna do one every two
months it has to be monthly
and then we went from
so about 10 productions in the first
year to 15 in the second year because we
brought in dalek empire as well nick
wanted to do something with daleks and
it was um
an opportunity to do something a bit
different and then it progressed from
there i think one of the criticisms
which is
given to big finish is that we produce
too much
and there's a slight reason for this
it's because we keep on getting over
excited
because we are at
at the core of it we're all fans and we
love to produce this stuff
and we want to
have
um we want to hear these stories
ourselves basically
um
there is a lot of wish fulfillment
within that i mean a very good example
of this
is doctor of war
i'll tell you where that came from it
was cribbed from um you know in the
twice upon a time episode when they are
reviewing the doctor's life
it ends up with them saying doctor of
war
[Music]
and i thought that's a nice twist on the
war doctor
and i thought well that goes into an
unbound
and i thought i want to see that i want
to listen to that production
and that's where that all came from so
we most of what we do comes from the
fact that we are massive fans and we're
doing stuff that we want to listen to
ourselves coming off doctor who for just
a hot second
i want to ask because i feel like this
i suspect the answer to this is going to
vary from license to license because i
know you do produce things that are
outside of doctor who as well
um when you acquire these licenses i
know that there are restrictions in
terms of what characters or whatever
that you are or aren't allowed to use
yes but within that framework how much
um creative freedom is big finish
granted do you have to actually run
story beats by the license holder or
once you clear what aspects you can use
you basically just get to do what you
want
there has been a change over the years
when we started 20 odd years ago
to be honest with you no one really
cared about what we do
um
now with every licensee they want to see
everything
because it's all about brand and the
word brand didn't exist 22 23 years ago
um
and
having a head of brand and brand
management is a very good thing because
it means that everything
is orchestrated things don't happen at
the same time people don't tread on each
other's toes you don't contradict each
other
it's it's a good idea um but it means
that
now
pretty much everything we do is run past
the license or
um
so
we would do we would
create a storyline that would go
we'd go through scripts etc etc we're
trusted because we've done this for so
long and we know the properties
um so there's
uh
it's not a question of trust it's just
so that everything is coordinated and
everything is um
uh
everything is in tune with itself if you
said i mean they're probably explaining
it badly
but no that that track so that that's
that's a thing that has been
um changing and evolving as sort of just
the landscape of how these licenses are
even handled at all has changed
yes yeah i mean originally there was
very little done
um because let's you know when we got
the doctor license for example in 99 it
was a little bit of a dead
um
show
obviously russell had other ideas
and it's fantastic that he's coming back
but he you know suddenly it became far
more important
and understandably everyone needed to
see storylines
and the example i always give is that we
had a storyline with queen victoria we
presented at the same time as they were
doing season one
and we were asked not to do queen
victoria and we went oh okay and we saw
season one and queen victoria wasn't
there but it was uh it was in season two
but russell already had that in mind he
had the first two seasons already mapped
out in his head
so um
yeah that's uh so sometimes we are asked
very rarely we're asked not to do
something for a bit
other times um
we're actually told
what might be happening
so that we can coordinate properly on it
if you say to me and i can't really give
you an example of that no i i i wouldn't
expect that you could um but it's so
it's quite interactive and it's great
that we have a number of people and not
just doctor who you quite rightly say um
things like the avengers for example the
people you work with on that they're
lovely and they really love that we're
doing the audio productions because it
brings alive a lot of stuff they don't
have because they had similar to doctor
who had so many of their episodes wiped
that this is a way of bringing them
alive again
and also um
really love working with the dark
shadows people they've been fantastic
not just the the actors but also the
guys who look after the estate as well
um
great stuff and similar with blake seven
um the terry nation state really
uh the fact that
new productions have been made of their
father's
work basically
it sort of keeps them alive a little bit
so i i know you always get asked you
know have you guys ever considered
ex-license or this or that and
you mentioned at the gallery panel that
the answer is probably yes but for
whatever reason you couldn't get it
so
what i want to ask instead is if we just
remove every logistical barrier and you
could just have whatever you wanted
what would your dream license be
that you have not already done here we
go right if there was no restrictions
and no negotiating i could just pick
like that
then star wars
star trek
james bond battlestar galactica
farscape
labyrinth terminator
blade runner
june
lord of the rings
you may have noticed i'm a geek
maybe a little i love the fact that you
not only had an answer you had a full
list ready to go and oh yeah yeah can i
just say which ones are those
you can see the ones we're not doing
obviously but i can't tell you which
ones we've contacted in the past but
well you've also saved me a follow-up
question but just by mentioning
firescape on your own because having
recently done my re-watch of that uh for
the podcast i do with jesse gender that
one's been on my mind a little bit
where's the bloody good series that's oh
it really is
yeah
um so
i want to ask you some specific things
about some of the specific decisions and
directions that have gone on with big
finish
okay um
and sort of starting with something that
i had addressed not all that long ago
uh in a video so the the recasting of
voices and of and of doctors so i guess
i just want to start in the broad sense
what kind of conversations one were
going on the when you very at the very
beginning first started doing that was
that something that there was a
reluctance to do or was there an
eagerness to to find a way to bring back
characters whose asters had passed
well if we go back
let's go back to the beginning of big
finish um we had access to three doctors
to start with as i said peter colin
sylvester
um
we
very quickly once we got sign of the
time in
and i was able to show
paul mcgann what we were trying to do
i sent paul mcgann
that and also a script for
something we haven't produced yet
which i think was holy terror
i want to say we had the script which
rob sherman because we we even then we
just read it and went this is a bloody
good script that's that's still my
favorite one for the record really there
you go we see we hit our stride nice and
early didn't we not saying that stuff
we've done recently isn't good stories
but we sent that script and
sirens to
paul's agents
they listened to him went yes fine yeah
great yeah right
um and then the thing that came back was
that paul
was filming hornblower at that time and
he had two young kids uh one of which
now works for us that's how long ago it
is
see that there we go it's ridiculous
isn't it so i remember jake
playing um
they had a
table football or football as you would
call them over there and um
and i used to play fuzzball with him
when he was like nine and he now works
for us that is ridiculous but um
he um
uh
paul said look i've got young kids i'm
doing hornblower all the time
if you um
i'll do it if we record in bristol where
my kids are
so we all went up there and we used to
record um four double discs back to back
up there and for season two we did six i
think and then we went back to four
again because it was so
time consuming to do that
um
so coming back to your question
when we started
uh paul mcgann you know we had
objectives we had the three doctors we
already knew paul mcgann came on board
loved it been there ever since then we
managed to work away at tom
and we got tom
about 10 years ago maybe 12 years ago
um
and
then we started to think
where do we go now
the unbound range was uh was a way of
testing the waters about recasting the
doctor as it were in terms of putting
new actors in the part
and
um when
the television series came back they
said we would prefer it if you didn't
recast the doctor again because
obviously
it gets into the press and
they become press news items that
someone's leaving because this person
has been cast to the doctor when in fact
what they've been asked to do is numb
bound for the big finish
so you can see how that becomes a little
bit complicated so we had kept with one
of the unbound doctors in davy warner
because he'd already been he'd already
played the part so we could come back to
him
and we
played that and then basically
we worked with an actor called tim
treloar tim trelor was
cast in the tom baker story
and
nick and tom were talking during lunch
and when i'm sure he reminds me i've met
him before or he reminds me of someone
and they were chatting away and then
thomas
is john perked with
and he went oh my god it wasn't exactly
like bertie but there was a lot of
poetry there just naturally
just the way he speaks so we tested the
water and i think for a lot of people
the the sales were
not great to start with i think there
was a lot of resistance to recasting
but there was a lot of stories we
couldn't tell
without having
um
a third doctor for example
the key moment though for
tim was doing legacy of time because uh
because it was all one box set with all
the doctors in it tim had his own disc
and a lot of people who hadn't heard tim
do the third doctor suddenly found him
and
in the six months after legacy came out
tim's sales went like that
because it was um a lot of people like
i'm not doing that i'm not oh
yeah i'll give it a go you know so it
was there was a lot of that going on and
um
that led us to think when we were
restructuring because
the the reason why the main range came
to an end is that the sales were doing
that and box sets for doing this
that was actually going to be something
i was going to ask as to whether the
ending of the monthly range and the
focus on box sets was was like a
business necessity
um
or or uh or whether that was more of a
creative decision it sounds like um like
it may have been a mix but it sounds
like it's leaning towards the former
there i think i think to be honest with
you everyone like working on the box
sets more because you've got to tell a
wider story
um so it wasn't just financial but when
i said look the guys they you know the
box sets are doing this and the these
are doing the everyone went to be honest
with you we'd much rather do the box
sets
so it became a okay this is slightly
pushing an open door
once we did the third doctor it did make
sense to the first and second
and part of the impetus on that was by
virtue of the fact if we get rid of if
we stopped doing the main range
and there was a lot of push to do it
before 275 it just mentally i thought
275 was a it isn't a round number at all
but it is a round number if you said i
mean in in my head um obviously a
rounded number is 300 but we would have
had to go on for another two years to do
that when we
finished the main range what it meant
was those three doctors who had been
inhabiting the main range were working
vertically
and it became more obvious that we could
do box sets for each individual doctor
and at that point bradley david bradley
is fantastic he's just never available
because he's one of the most working
actors we love working with him in no
way is are we stopping working with
david bradley and we've said that but i
was i was asked so many times at
gallifrey about you're not dropping
david bradley the answer is no we're not
in fact we're planning something with
him at the moment it's his availability
um and that's great but he will always
make time for us because he loves
playing the doctor
um but it made sense that if we were
going to cast a new actor to play the
second doctor
and michael made it very clear to us
that he wanted to do it uh michael
trouten um it would mean that we would
have
our doctors for all these funds but not
the first so getting in a new first
doctor
made sense
and
it's interesting isn't it the first
doctor is
probably the most recast doctor in
history
you've got five doctors you've got david
bradley's interpretation arguably you've
got peter cushing as well as another
version of this doctor and then we've
got our version the first doctor there's
been a lot of actors playing the first
doctor but i've i've gone on record to
say tim trade will not be the last actor
to play the third doctor
and i should underline as i did when we
were chatting at gallifrey that
these are not people
doing impersonations
they are very good actors
tim's an rsc actor who has a voice which
sounds similar to the third doctor
and he leans into that
and he is acting he's not impersonating
um so they bring their own character
traits to it and
that's a development in the same way
that bradley did
he's not mimicking hartnell he's
bringing some of the attributes of the
first doctor into his performance as the
first doctor i want to ask a little bit
about some possible uh unforeseen
consequences of
bringing in as many um new actors to
play old characters because like
we have gotten to the point where you
now have a release like the annihilators
which has the second doctor the third
doctor the brigadier liz shaw and jamie
mcraman and only one of those five is
voiced by the original actor yeah
absolutely did do you
feel uh that
the sort of the breaking of that seal
and starting to do that has possibly led
to a
diminishment in more long-term original
characters like a lot of the original
companions that used to be introduced or
things like that because now you
suddenly have access to stuff that it
makes creating new things almost
redundant you have hit a nail on the
head that i didn't even know was was
sticking out the wall
um
that's very interesting
uh
i will bring this up with everyone else
vera because i
uh
i hadn't even thought of that but you're
absolutely right
and
we have a problem with big finished
companions in that we fall in love with
them as you may have noticed charlie
the original intention was for charlie
to die
in zagreus
and we couldn't pull the trigger because
if you think about it that character was
built up to die
um and it never happened because we love
india fishing um
at gallifrey actually as you may have
noticed very embarrassingly
india and i got slightly drunk in the
bar on saturday night because we hadn't
seen each other in a number of years
um and we were just
in each other's company and she is the
most lovely woman and
you know we just couldn't pull the
trigger um similar things sort of
started to happen with sheridan as lucy
miller
but what happened there was
sheridan suddenly became one of the most
successful actresses in the uk
one baftas won olivier awards and it got
to the point where she was being she was
taking bikes um courier bikes from set
to our studios to record for a few hours
get back on the fight and get back on
set and they were having to release her
from films and television shows to come
and record with us and it got to the
point where he's like oh my god having a
nightmare
for her and for us and
so we thought you know what
we're looking at the character and it
would have a massive impact if she died
at the end um big spoiler if you haven't
heard all the lucy miller stuff you
should have by now it's been out forever
um but
she dies
and it's
one of the
most devastating things we've ever done
in the studio because
india talks about it but all companions
do it i can guarantee it
um phil olivier did it as well um is
that you you flip through and go just
checking and i'm still alive
and and she and sheridan did this all
the time because she could see which way
this was going and she'd flip through
and go and then one day she flipped
through and went oh i've
died so she came into the studio like
this
and we were like hello
she was like i don't want to go and it's
like i know i know
and we sat down nick and i sat down with
her
on
on this little bench outside
and we gave her a hug and we were like
um you're amazing nick actually said one
of the most perceptive things that nick
ever said about um about anything
anything he's not very perceptive guys
but um no he is um one of the most
perceptive things he ever said was at
some point
everyone else is going to figure out how
brilliant sheridan is
and then we're screwed and that's pretty
much what happened um it took him four
years but it happened
what uh we gave her a great big hug and
told her how much we loved her and she
went in there and gave an amazing
performance and paul mcgann gave an
amazing performance as well if you
remember the bit at the end where he's
talking to the recorder he's listening
to her and then speaking to her and
she's gone but he's listening to her
voice
um he gave an amazing performance
and we were like wow okay
let's go down the pub and he went no no
i can do it better than that
and and i was like right okay so he went
again and he was even better because it
meant so much to him because sheridan he
had got on so well he'd done a tv show
with her when she was 16
and when we said oh your new companion
is going to be sharon smith he was like
brilliant i love her
and he just loved working with her and
when she came back it was just like old
times when she came back for the uh the
special uh fur adventures um box that we
did it was great to have him back so
here's the thing we fall in love with
our original creations
and then we don't let them go
and the thing about doctor who is
historically
you have a companion or a new companion
every one two three seasons
that is one of the ways the series keeps
on being fresh i was talking to phil
philip olivier about this
and phil was on brookside for years uh
which is a soap over in the uk and he
says you do realize i've been working
for a big finish more than half my life
and it's the longest gig i've ever done
and it's like yeah fair enough
so one of the things that we haven't
done is that we
haven't created new companions in a
while who were original original but
what we have done is we brought to life
again companions who may not be with us
anymore
and um
and
to
create
eras that we didn't have access to
before because we didn't have the actors
available have you seen me
so
i think that has been a phase but it is
something like which you know what you
pointed out you're absolutely right
and i hadn't really thought about it
enough that we haven't been creating any
new companions so maybe we'll have to
sit down and make a new companion
um
i'll i'll happily take a co-creation and
credit on that
um
so like first of all i just want to make
the observation so i feel like what you
said about falling in love with charlie
and intending to kill her and then not
probably as a result of that you
probably have more sympathy for stephen
moffat's inability to let clara stay
dead than i do as a result of that
i totally get that 110
um so i'm gonna actually kind of branch
off about what we're just talking about
with
um it's not a direct thing but i think
it does have impact on sort of the next
thing i want to talk about which is some
of the
a representation
that uh is present for minority groups
within the range that you do
um
and the way it's connected is that
obviously if you're dipping into
existing characters they already are
what they are
um now
uh through the admittedly uh somewhat
rushed uh research that i was able to do
it does look like um lgbtq plus
characters started getting introduced
about a decade ago we had characters
like oliver harper um orr who's
non-binary on torchwood uh there was
calypso jones just a couple years ago
who was a non-binary character played by
a non-binary actor i was very happy to
see that but um
i i did notice and this was just kind of
based off of
like looking at the covers of the range
doctor who especially
is very monochrome there's uh there's an
awful lot of white people torchwood
seems to have a little bit more
um racial diversity
but i wonder if with that or something
like uh disability representation
is part of the reason that we don't have
as much of that in big finish
because those are things that are easier
to signify visually than
through audio or is that just something
that hasn't even been actively thought
about and is just an accidental
byproduct
no we we have thought about it a lot
actually um we are casting a lot more
um
uh
people of color um and um
and also
you know we've
it's more about getting in people who
are really good at the job
okay
yeah
of course always
we we recently we've taken on new
producer dom who is
bloody fantastic and actually saving our
lives on a number of things um and it's
important to get new young voices in
and also different cultural voices as
well
and we're very actively doing that the
worst thing that could happen is that i
as a 54 year old white male who's middle
class
suddenly starts saying we need to be hip
and cool and bring in all these people
just for the sake of it it's got to be
for
good reasons and they they've got to do
a good job and we've been finding a lot
of very good people who can do that
and
um
when it comes to diversity of casting
that is happening a lot you know we've
been very lucky in finding someone like
rebecca root who brings so much to the
character and a lot of life experience
which is which is transformed within the
character
um and
um
[Music]
we we we do work with non-binary actors
the television series which i've just
sent you the trailer for as you will see
is actually created by
a 17 year old teenage girl
and her non-binary best mate
what was so important about it was that
it was giving me insights into areas
which i had no i didn't really know
about
and um
because it was co-created by someone
who's non-binary it taught me a lot
about their lives and um
and how they feel about a number of
different different issues so i think
it's it's uh it's a very important piece
and i was very happy to have got it
produced
it's something that we we actively
look for is good creatives who can give
us a different
and different perspective on life
which is great i am
because i'm gonna get annoyed with
myself if i don't okay i just wanna i
wanna push back on one little thing
about one specific bit of wording that
that you said
yes and i'm just going to caution you
about this mindset
so there was a there was a point in your
answer where you said you know we want
to be sure that we're bringing these
people in
you know for the right reasons and for
good reason or something very close to
that
yeah
be cautious of that mindset
because that is not a requirement to
bring in a straight white character
nobody says there has to be a good
reason to bring in a white character or
a able-bodied character or as straight
says hec character they only ever say
that there should be a good reason to do
anything other than that so just be
cautious of the mindset
we're gonna drop this in um just real
quick as an insert because we kind of we
kind of um
like realized some stuff about the
conversation in terms of having more
minority performers and in in specific
there was something that
i simply didn't realize in terms of how
things differ in the uk versus the u.s
that uh was actually really helpful for
for me to hear from you i um
i'm actually gonna quote from real
figures because um
i knew there was a big disparity in uh
the percentage of how the
the population is made up in the us
against the uk
so um i did some research and um in the
u.s um
you have
57
are white
uh in the uk
only 3.3
of the population is black
one of the things that
i know i've spoken to both arts ed which
is and mount view which are two very
leading colleges for both actors and
creatives in the uk and they pull
through a lot of very good actors a lot
of good directors and a lot of good
producers and i've done some lecturing
there both art said and at mount view
and both of them are committed to
bringing forward
more
black and
asian talent
into
acting producing and directing
one of the biggest problems we have is
that um even though it's only 3.3
percent are black in the uk black actors
are underrepresented
in the mix
of the total number of actors in the uk
so it's actually less than three percent
of actors are black and and then of
course there's the fact that like that's
just working on a much smaller pool and
then you still have to audition and find
someone who's actually going to work for
the part
there's only 70 000 actors in the uk
so if less than three percent are black
that means there's 2 000 actors in the
uk who are available who are black
now there is this issue
which is that
not every actor is brilliant you have
the most amazing actors and you have
actors who are not quite as good
and
obviously you want to cast the best
actors for the best parts so if for
example you say
that across the board
50 percent of actors are less good than
the other 50 of actors you get into a
situation where
there are
um
your pool is even smaller
if you said i mean if you want to cast
really good actors in really good roles
now
because the the percentage is so small
as well i was looking at some figures
from the british film institute earlier
and
um they were showing that 59
of movies made in the uk have no black
actors in at all now obviously that is
something which
everyone is working to change
and within big finish
we have made a number of strides in the
last few years of introducing more and
more black asian
transgender and um
and
differently abled actors
so for example
recently we cast ruth madeley who's a
wheelchair user as the first uh doctor
companion who uses a wheelchair which is
going to be very interesting as we go
forward storytelling wise we've also
brought back brigadier bambera for
example angela bruce which has been
amazing i can't wait for people to hear
what she delivers because she has loved
coming back to the part so much
if there was a criticism in the past
maybe we weren't
thinking enough
about being as inclusive as we should
have been
but i think in the last five years we
have done a lot of work to try and
improve that
and to bring more and more
good black characters
into our
series
um but not just that it's also asian
actors as well
there is a
disparity in the number of asian actors
available
and it's it's worse than than black
actors although the um population in the
uk is about seven percent asian it's
very underrepresented
underrepresented in the number of asian
actors available
to um to us
and um i think that's an area which we
can improve we should be having more
asian actors working with us
well i i think the reason i really
wanted to to get this
added into the conversation we'd already
had is there was a little bit and we
didn't realize it until after
the interview that there's a there was
kind of a fundamental disconnect because
you had an inherent understanding of uk
demographics whereas the vast majority
of times whenever i'm looking at
representation i'm looking at hollywood
productions which is a completely
different ballgame between how much
bigger the us is how much different the
demographics are and how diverse the
population of a place like los angeles
where a lot of the core los angeles and
new york with a lot of the core casting
is so i'd gotten very used to
being very dismissive of anything that
sounded like an excuse to not look into
minority actors
because the demographic realities where
i live
are such that i don't i it comes across
much more as an excuse
versus very different demographic
realities in the uk which i frankly had
never thought to take into account
it's very interesting isn't it and i'm
very glad to have this conversation with
you because um if for example we were
given um 20 auditions on audio and we
didn't know the um ethnicity of anyone
that would had auditioned for us
um
there is such a small pool of black
actors the chances are that if if we
were just sent through 20 auditions all
20 of them would be white
the the chances are they will it's very
easy for us to cast all white casting if
you said i mean we actually have to
actively work to make sure we're
representative and one of the key
factors here is actually the one which
you've picked up on which is that we're
producing not just for the uk but for
the world and it's very important that
we actually
represented a world view not just a uk
view
and i think we've been working far more
towards that in the last few years and
um
we have some really exciting uh casting
that's coming up and i can't tell you
what it is
because it's embargoed at the moment um
but one but you're gonna be thrilled
when it happened i'm sure
i'm sure that i will be and and i don't
think there's too much more to add
beyond what we've said but i really
wanted to get this in there because
i i try and be as accounting for the
logistical realities of
any production that i i bring up
representation as i can and this was
frankly just a reality that i
i hadn't formed a proper picture of in
my head so it's something that i i
really appreciate you elaborating on and
it it it gives me i think a better
understanding when i talk about uk
productions um not to say that i won't
encourage more organizations to do what
you um are appearing to do which is to
make more of a concerted effort but
understanding that
it does take more deliberate effort
whereas in the u.s you almost have to go
out of your way to have to well
um as you say in los angeles if you put
out a general casting call probably 40
percent of the actors coming in would be
black
so
black hispanic something other than
white certainly so it's just a slightly
different um
it means that we have to be more
proactive basically but it's something
that we really really passionately
believe in i think if you look at
some of the casting we've done in the
last few years you can see which way
we're going and also the casting of
rebecca root for example as the first
transgender companion
um i think is an important step as well
to make this
a more inclusive
world in doctor who certainly
appreciative of that so thank you one of
the things somewhat related to this that
i just you don't actually even have to
comment on this if you're not
comfortable doing so but i do just want
to point out my own personal
appreciation with james dreyfus after he
made his statements uh in regards to his
feelings about the transgender community
that he did not continue to be
uh employed there and again if you do or
don't want to speak on that but i do
have an appreciation
of that because it's become an issue in
many areas where
um performers or writers will
say these things and the people
employing them won't appreciate that
continuing to employ them after that
is at the very least saying that this is
okay and we don't have a problem with it
james came along did his contract and
that's probably all i can say about that
um
as i'm probably you'd probably
appreciate and that's i mean that's the
way these things tend to be it tends to
they always get reported as like person
fired wherein the the legal reality is
person contract not renewed which is not
actually the same thing uh we are sort
of coming uh towards the tail end of our
time so
i wanted to ask you
if and this might be hard to pick one
thing i'll let you pick multiple
with everything that you've done with
everything that big finish has
uh accomplished or is working on
is there something that stands out as an
aspect be it a specific story a
character or a or working with a certain
actor what are you most proud
at having helped bring about
now that's
that's very interesting because it's a
very broad canvas which i've worked it
it is i've given you a lot of options
and if you're anything like me you get
paralyzed by choice so yeah that you've
just done that to me however
um what i would say is um
i think it's uh
i tell you what i found it i found it
okay i have found it
um working with terran sticks so when i
grew up we didn't have repeats on
television we didn't have
um
we didn't have videos available to us we
didn't have
the uh
we didn't have dvds whatever we had the
books
so i was an avid reader of terence dix's
books
and for me reading those um books was
time traveling and going back and
discovering
adventures which i didn't know about
before i was able to read about the
second doctor the first doctor the third
doctor stuff that i hadn't seen on
television uh or could barely remember
um
and
when i worked with terence on um the
ultimate adventure
um i got the chance to script edit him
and for him to say here's the script
let's talk about it because obviously it
was a stage play not an audio drama so
things had to change
and we went through all that with him
and actually the opportunity to work
with terence and actually talk about
stuff and his very clear understanding
of what doctor who is
and who the doctor is was fascinating
and was one of those moments which i
will
cherish forever
i always delight when
ever
you know someone who can be a creative
inspiration is brought up that every
story i ever hear about that person is
only ever
positive and how wonderful they were and
he he seems to have been one of those
figures where
good luck finding anyone to say a mean
thing about him
you won't because he was such a
collaborator i think this is why barry
let's love working with him so much and
they were able to it's very one of the
very few
teams where they switched around so for
example on his classic series sunday
night classic series um it ends up with
barry being the scripts editor
effectively and terence being the
producer
that's incredibly rare that you can do
that
and that's because they had such trust
in each other and effectively they
worked together so well and part of that
i'm sure is because terence was so
flexible
and and so lovely to work with i i do i
did work with him prior to that as well
a doctor's spin-off video called
shakedown i i have heard of it that's
one of the things i have not tracked
down as yet
it's it's it's great fun but the scripts
by terence and it's a very traditional
doctor who esque story about son tyrons
and um
the ending um was reasonably
straightforward and i suggested a few
changes to it and terence was like
that's brilliant let's do this and this
and this and i got to see how
collaborative he was
and the end result was brilliant
um i'm not saying i was brilliant i'm
saying that appearance i gave an idea to
terence which he ran with much better
than i would have done
and um but he just wanted everything to
be good
so i think um i i spent there was a
convention he did before
lockdown happened um
and
uh
we
i i spent an evening with terence um
it's probably five years ago now and
it was just lovely to be in his presence
and as you say you won't find anyone
who's got a bad word to say about
terence so we are almost out of time but
i'm going to give you
and no this has been wonderful i'm going
to give you what i call the free space
so anything that you had hoped i would
ask or have give you the chance to talk
about that i didn't or uh anything uh
you've mentioned the uh the upcoming tv
show i will put information for that in
the description but anything else you
feel like uh plugging or mentioning uh
what can i plug and mention oh i've got
um
a new new musical going into the west
end
um called bonnie and clyde which opens
at the arts theatre in april it was on
broadway 10 years ago
and it's a it's an updated version of it
and hopefully a lot of people come and
see that
um we've got a lot of great stuff coming
up for the anniversary year with doctor
who
most of which i can't tell you obviously
but there's two or three bits where i'm
going oh that is ridiculous
and i'm so excited about it's so weird
because we've already planned
23 24 25 26
we're on to a lot of 27 right now
and
as i said we get
over enthusiastic
about this stuff and we we go great
let's do this let's do this let's do
this and we run ahead of ourselves so
but um
we have got
some very special things for the
anniversary year so
in the words of jnc stay tuned
well jason thank you so much for your
time this has been a wonderful
conversation thank you very much i just
want to thank jason one more time for
sitting down and talking to me i had a
wonderful time speaking with him now
multiple times uh it's been a joy to do
and i hope that all of you folks enjoyed
the results found it interesting
insightful
a way to pass an hour whatever works
uh i'm able to do this as my living and
work with schedules from people in
completely different time zones than me
because i don't have to hold down a day
job and that is maintained by the fact
that patreon is what supports
me and my ability to do this any amount
you're able to um contribute there is of
immense help if you can't the like share
subscribe that all helps me out you can
check out other projects that i have on
other sites books i've written etc etc
but don't worry too much about that
the main thing that i really need you to
remember is
you're beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings occasionally even with guests
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin lutfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
nobulax the poodle idolm tracy scrabba
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor shane ross robin moore
shayla gourley and brendan the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]